Speaker 1: All right, so let's do one more
sort of awkward moment in the aftermath to
the Colin Powell death that we reported on
yesterday, I mentioned in the first segment
how Fox News reporter John Roberts tweeted
something completely insane about the death
in vaccines.
And then quickly deleted it.
Well, it got even weirder when then Fox News
brought on a guest to talk about people that
are reacting and saying things that are wrong.
And John Roberts was sitting there very awkwardly,
as Dr. Nicole Sapir was essentially describing
what John Roberts said without actually naming
him.
So let's, let's kind of like refresh this
entire thing.
John Roberts tweeted yesterday after the death
of Colin Powell was announced.
The fact that Colin Powell died from a breakthrough
COVID infection raises new concerns about
how effective vaccines are long term now.
That's not true.
We knew that immunocompromised people like
Colin Powell would mount less on average of
a of an immune response.
We know that the older you are and Colin Powell
was 84, the more likely you are to die from
COVID.
Obviously, that goes down with being vaccinated,
but vaccinated populations, the older you
are, the more likely you are to die from COVID
and unvaccinated as well.
It's sort of a distribution that that is like
that.
So John Roberts quickly deleted this tweet.
So then Fox News brings on Dr. Nicole Saffir
and John Roberts is on screen.
And Nicole Savior's says this doesn't mean
the vaccines don't work.
This stuff has to stop.
A lot of people are spreading nonsense and
John Roberts looking very uncomfortable because
she doesn't name him, but he had just gotten
done tweeting this nonsense and then deleting
it, something that you want
Speaker 4: to get out there in the wake of
Colin Powell's death that you want people
to know because obviously there's a lot of
information to take in on this.
Final thought from you?
Well, I can tell you, Sandra.
It's very it's very upsetting to see that
people taking Colin Powell's death and using
it as the vaccine didn't work.
Speaker 1: Oh, well, that's exactly what John
Roberts did.
And now he's going to sit there and listen
to you.
This is
Speaker 4: a very specific situation and one
to use someone's death to try and make a point
that really doesn't carry a lot of weight
to
Speaker 1: it.
Oh, that's exactly what John Roberts was doing.
He was trying to make a point that carries
no weight.
Using Colin Powell's death
Speaker 4: is is very frustrating.
But I can tell you that this was a very specific
situation.
You had an elderly gentleman.
I know that people don't like that word, but
at the age of eighty four, he was already
vulnerable for COVID 19.
And then you add a cancer of the blood, and
he is the most vulnerable when it comes to
COVID 19.
Our thoughts are with his family for sure
at this moment after learning of his death
this morning.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah.
John Roberts Oh yeah, very much.
Yes, of course.
Well, he's the guy who just did exactly that.
He looked uncomfortable and he should look
uncomfortable.
And it is.
It is an instructive lesson in if we already
know that while the vaccine reduces your risk
of hospitalization and death dramatically,
it is not 100 percent.
And then one well-known person dies.
It actually changes nothing.
It changes nothing about our overall understanding
of the vaccine's effectiveness.
It's just we know the name of this person.
It's a well-known person.
That's what it changes.
And these I don't know if they're opportunists.
I don't know if they're simply ignorant.
I don't know if they're bad people who use
this as they see it, as opening the door to
tweet exactly what John Roberts tweeted, which
he was then later shamed, or someone who called
him and said, you really should pull that
down.
It is not serious thinking, and these are
not serious contributions to our understanding
of how vaccination works, and
they shouldn't be considered that